لقد شهدنا هنا في الدوحة
وصول هؤلاء الأمريكيين الخمسة الذين
تم احتجازهم خطأً في إيران. كنت
هنا على مدرج المطار
أغطي ذلك قبل أسابيع فقط، وليس
فقط المكان الذي هبط فيه هؤلاء السجناء السابقون لأول مرة، بل
كان أيضًا  في قلب
ما كانت مفاوضات مرهقة أكثر
من سنة من الوساطة أه من قبل
مسؤولي المطاعم وهذه ليست
المرة الأولى التي يقوم فيها كاتا كوسيط
تحدثت عن ذلك قبل فترة مع
وزير الدولة محمد بن
عبد العزيز الكي  في قلب تلك
المفاوضات ناقشنا ذلك
واستمعوا أكثر، لم يكن الأمر سهلاً، لم يكن سهلاً،
كان أه عدة رحلات وأه عدة
تحركات من فندق إلى آخر،
وهذا أيضًا كان أه لم يكن سهلاً
ولكن بكل سرور  مع الفريق الذي
لدينا في الدوحة تمكنا من أه
التأكد من إيصال الرسالة بوضوح إلى
الأطراف وتقريبهم من التوصل إلى
اتفاق وبكل سرور تمكنا من القيام
بذلك، ما هو الدور الذي قد يلعبه C الآن
في المضي قدمًا  التفاوض على اتفاق
نوع من الاتفاق حول الملف النووي
بين الولايات المتحدة وإيران أه قار
نعتقد بشدة أن كجزء من سياستها الخارجية هو
المشاركة بنشاط في
عملية صنع السلام في منطقتنا
ودوليا وجزء من ذلك
تم تكليفنا أه أم  من قبل عدة دول
أه أه أه للمشاركة للعب دور في
الوساطة بين أه إيران والعديد من
الدول الأخرى بما في ذلك
دول الاتحاد الأوروبي أه الآن فيما يتعلق
بالمحادثات النووية لقد أمضى
وقتا طويلا الآن أه للأطراف أن
يناقشوها هو  ليس موضوعا سهلا أه أه و أه
أه لكننا ما زلنا ملتزمين
بلعب أه أه هذا الدور ونحاول أه
التأكد من أننا نجد أرضية مشتركة
بدعم بالطبع من أه
المنسق الأوروبي المختار لدى الولايات المتحدة منذ بعض
الوقت  شجعت هذه المنطقة على
ترتيب ساحتها الخلفية، إنها
منطقتنا لتسوية
قضاياها وصراعاتها، ماذا عن
ملف إسرائيل وفلسطين قبل أن ننتقل إلى هذا الموضوع،
وهو أحد أهم
المواضيع الأساسية والأساسية لـ أه لـ أه لنا  في
الشرق الأوسط أم موقفنا
واضح جداً فيما يتعلق
بقضية فلسطين أم أن الفلسطينيين بحاجة إلى
منح حقوقهم حقوق أه
الحرية وحقوق أه الأرض
وأعتقد أه تلك الأمور بحاجة إلى
حل  بأي طريقة ممكنة وفي أي
نوع من الاتفاق الذي سيتم
أخذه في الاعتبار ولذلك أه نحن
نقول دائمًا أن حل قطعة واحدة من
اللغز سيساعدك على الفهم
والانتقال إلى الحالات الأخرى
أيضًا حتى تكون قصة واحدة ناجحة  داخل
المنطقة من المرجح أن يؤثر بشكل
إيجابي على الحالات الأخرى التي نجدها
في
المنطقة. لماذا تعتقد أن البلدان
في جميع أنحاء العالم لديها الثقة في
الكاتا للمساعدة في لعب دور الوساطة هذا
لتكون في قلب هذه المفاوضات،
الوساطة ليست كذلك  طريقة أه جديدة
لقطر يعني لدينا
خبرة طويلة جداً أه في هذا
المجال منذ أكثر من 25 سنة شاركنا
في عدة أعمال وساطة
ونتجت بنجاح بين
الأطراف المنتقلة من أه وكينيا
تشاد  أفغانستان الوضع طبعا
في فلسطين و و لبنان وغيرها
لذلك أه أه بسبب هذا السجل أه قطر
أصبحت أكثر ثقة من
الدول الدولية أه تلعب دورا فيها في
حل النزاعات تلعب هذا النوع من دور
الجسر أم في بعض الأحيان أه
مواقف الحياد بشأن
ملف أوكرانيا، لقد كنت في الواقع تعرف
صراحةً إلى حد ما بشأن ذلك، نعم ماذا
عن المساعدة في إيجاد حل
للصراع الأوكراني الروسي؟ أعتقد أننا
كنا واضحين وشفافين للغاية منذ
اليوم الأول للمسائل التي تعتمد على
المواثيق المتحدة والقانون الدولي
لا نستطيع أن نقف أه أه في دعم
أي شيء مخالف للقانون
الدولي أه يهم عندما أه
يحبذ العنف وأه أه أه
اختيار الأساليب أه أه غير
متوافق مع ميثاق الأمم المتحدة والقانون
الدولي لا يمكننا دعمه
لذلك كنا دائما شفافين
وواضحين فيما يتعلق برأينا لكن هذا
لا يعني أن هذا أه سيزيل
الثقة أو الثقة في قطر
للعب دور أكبر في تلك الزاوية
بصراحة لا أعتقد أن كون أه أه  إن
الوضوح والشفافية فيما يتعلق
بموقفك السياسي بشأن قضية ما
سيمنعك من لعب دور
وساطة مهم للغاية